as we have for the last several weeks we
want to take a moment to tell you about
some of the remarkable people we've lost
to the corona virus pandemic while some
were known to the world others were only
known to their loved ones but all made a
big difference in their own way here are
just some of the many lives to remember
[Music]
aeronautical engineer Richard Passman
was a pioneer whose top-secret work
helped change the course of the Cold War
when I was 18
a Navy training pilot in world war ii
Passman would work on the bell x-1 the
first plane to break the sound barrier
in 1947 and the bell x2 the first to
achieve mach 3 a GE he helped develop
the first spy satellite and did
breakthrough work on missile warheads he
was a Renaissance man said his son bill
he played piano baked bread and was
married to his wife Mina for 70 years
richard Passman was 94 hey soos Roman
Melendez was a cook at one of New York's
most acclaimed restaurants for 20 years
he worked at nougatine
run by renowned chef jean-georges
Vongerichten he was part of the glue
that held everything and everyone
together chef George said Melendez who
came to New York from his native Mexico
City in 1994 was the best dad said his
daughter Justin he would come home from
work tired but always spend time with us
no matter what
he was known for nurturing young cooks
said chef mark l'épée Co he had a love
for music a razor-sharp wit and a
presence only wisdom and experience can
afford a man hey Zeus Roman Melendez was
49
Selma Esther Ryan died in this pandemic
more than a century after her older
sister died in the Spanish flu pandemic
at age five in 1919 they never met each
other Selma's daughter Vicki Spencer
said but they're together now
Selma grew up in Hearne Ville Texas and
married bud Ryan a fighter pilot in the
Air Force they had the love affair of
the century Vicki said everywhere we
moved she made us feel safe and secure
Selma Esther Ryan was 96 April Dunne was
a fierce advocate for the disabled who
worked for Louisiana Governor John bel
Edwards office of disability affairs
born with fetal alcohol syndrome and
cerebral palsy Dunn championed the
marginalized at the State Capitol April
didn't want her disability to limit her
said her mom Jeanette Dunn who adopted
April when she was 5 months old April
also loved to celebrate birthdays her
own and her co-workers said her
supervisor Bambi Paulette Zola every day
was a memory with April April Dunn was
33 Hayley Herrera was one class away
from her master's degree in marriage and
Family Therapy she had a 4.0 average and
had so much more to offer her mother
Valerie said friends went to her for
advice that's why she wanted to be a
therapist this virus is a devil in
disguise Valerie said never in a million
years did I imagine I would lose my
daughter Haley Herrera was 25
Billy Birmingham was an emergency
medical technician with the Kansas City
Missouri Fire Department known for his
big warm heart he had a presence about
him and was always able to calm his
patients said Nathan hopper his
ambulance partner Birmingham was also a
pastor who started his own church and a
father of six who loved taking his kids
on adventures we just want to thank
Kansas City as a whole for loving on my
dad
Kansas City gave Birmingham a hero's
send-off a tribute that included a fire
department escort a flyover for its
native son the last alarm for Billy
Birmingham has now ended he has gone
home
Billy Birmingham was 69